[Musique]
angie elle pense elle respire cinéma
réalisatrice et fondatrice de
l'association ciné cours elsa dahmani
met tout en oeuvre pour développer la
filière cinéma dans notre île
plus qu'un talent la course et une
maîtresse du septième art qui nous
attend ici sur un tournage
merci est à damas ni de nous accueillir
la sur le court métrage de
sainte-suzanne alors qu'est ce qui se
passe ici avec les jeunes donc c'est le
c'est un stage qu on offre à des jeunes
contre 15 et 25 ans qui souhaitent
qu'ils sont passionnés des métiers de
l'audiovisuel du cinéma et qui
souhaitant découvrir davantage et ils
sont encadrés pendant deux semaines par
des intervenants professionnels ils
écrivent ensemble un court métrage de
fiction et il le tourne
et puis après ils vont le montrer aux
habitants etc
il présentait et c'est un peu la
première le premier pas vers les métiers
du cinéma aux côtés de court métrage a
aussi un talent la course est repartie
oui talent la courbe donc les on reçoit
les candidatures jusqu'au 10 janvier
donc des porteurs de projets de courts
métrages de fiction qui souhaite le
développer dans des conditions
professionnelles et est là donc on a une
la nouvelle promo donc ça sera la
troisième 2021-2022 qu on accompagnera à
partir de mars prochain donc 2021
surtout que la première promotion on
voit que ça se concrétise notamment avec
vincent fonta
césar est ce que il apparaît comme un
modèle aujourd'hui le parcours de
vincent il ay là il fait vraiment mouche
même au niveau national puisqu'il a
quand même décroché le prix français les
visions du court métrage de l'année 2020
dont surtout les courts métrages acheté
par france télé c'est un film de la
réunion qui qui qui sort qui émergent et
qui est intégralement par les en créole
qui est vraiment un film d'auteur avec
une force est donc de commencer talent
la cour avec un lauréat comme vincent
frontanau c est bien sûr je pense à bien
la barre un peu haut mais mais mais ça
fait c'est un grand bonheur et elsa tu
es aussi réalisatrice
c'est là
le cinéma c'est venu comment alors le
cinéma ge
c'est venu depuis tout petit ce que je
suis un peu tombé dedans quand j'étais
petit ce que mon père et réalisateur ça
ça m'a vraiment donné la force de croire
justement qu'il ya de la place pour les
autres pour ceux qui ne correspondent
pas forcément aux cases
[Musique]
allez coco je peux vous en dire un mot à
l'écossé un court métrage que j'ai
réalisé en 2015
et qui a été pour moi une première
pierre dans vers la fiction puisque je
voulais à l'époque j'ai cru un long
métrage et j'ai compris par aller coco
que vraiment le cours était la porte
d'entrée
et puis à travers ce court métrage avait
envie de commencer cette passerelle de
tisser cette passerelle entre un monde
du cinéma français très centralisé quand
même à paris avec des décideurs quand
même parisien et et nous à la réunion
toute cette émulation toute cette
créativité et ses histoires incroyables
qu'on ne connaît pas forcément sur
l'examen de ma vie au regard des
dépressifs qui envoie tout ce que tu
fais tout ce que tu corps pour
développer cette filière ces débats à la
réunion qu'est ce qui te pousse qu'est
ce qui te motive c'est ce qui motive
c'est d'avoir envie
des jeunes qui est plus de diversité au
cinéma qu'on soit mieux représentée dans
toutes nos diversités la société
française dans toute sa globalité
pour moi la réunion elle elle porte
cette diversité là
et si tu avais un mot justement à dire à
ceux qui ont un rêve à réaliser mais qui
ont du mal encore à se décider
qu'est ce que tu leur dirai
je dirais que
il faut qu'ils croient en eux que le
temps ne fait rien à faire dans le sens
où il est toujours temps de doser et de
faire tout pour que le chemin
progressivement petit à petit amène vers
la réalisation de son rêve est de faire
des choix pas forcément tout de suite le
grand choix énorme qui demande beaucoup
de courage et peut-être d'inquiétude et
c est peut être petit à petit et d'aller
d'oser y aller et et qu'il ya de la
place pour tout le monde
osons ensemble j'ai envie de dire merci
beaucoup elle t'a dahmani
merci beaucoup